greetings from podcastville it's
thursday the 14th
of january uncle joey's joint is brought
to you by
draftkings listen the party starts
tonight
it starts tonight you got a tnt
doubleheader
plus i got two games that the lines
don't even look good on them
take a look at the lines of the indy
portland nba game
and the miami philly nba game the lights
don't look the lines don't look right
right there i go to draftkings that's
where the action starts
sports are in full swing there's no
shortage of [__] action you got a ufc
card this weekend i think ufc fight
island seven
i mean come on and this is the best
place to get in on it
draftkings america's top rated sports
book
if you haven't tried them yet what the
[__] are you waiting for
to celebrate the nfl playoffs draftkings
is giving all new players a great offer
this weekend bet on any football game at
a hundred to one odds
joey what are you saying bet any of the
four football games at a 100 to one odds
that's right all you got to do is bet a
dollar on any football game this weekend
for a chance to win
100 bucks plus basketball season is
[__] on fire
they don't have their [__] lines
right and you're sitting there talking
about [__] you know
is is are the eagles going on tour this
summer who gives a [__]
i'm looking to make money tonight
[__] you got indy portland
miami philly go to draftkings download
the top rated
sports book app right now it's safe
secure
reliable and it's your [__] money
deposit and withdrawal at your
convenience
right now today before anything let's
get the action started tonight thursday
night
download the top rated draftking
sportsbook app now
use promo code joey j-o-e-y when you
sign up to get
100 to one odds on any football game
this weekend
that's called joey for new players to
get a shot at any
at 100 on any football action
this weekend for a limited time only at
draftking sports mode
but the party starts tonight like i said
you got some weak lines on indy portland
miami philly go make some money there's
a parlay in there for you i can't give
it to you
make go to a friend who knows nba so
right now
here's the part the lawyers make me
[__] say all right indiana
pennsylvania new jersey tennessee
colorado
restrictions apply see draftkings.com
slash sports book forget details now
if you got a gambling problem i don't
want the kiss of death around there's
help for you
call 1-800 gambler and if you're in
indiana call 1-809 with it
but if you're solid you're grounded
you're ready to make some [__]
guitars
download the draftking sportsbook app
use code joey
and cash in on this deal the joint is
also brought to you by
blue chew it's the second week of
january and you're still staying single
scratching your head where do i go do i
go nintendo no matter if you show up
whatever site you show up
you better have a big dick and a nice
attitude and i'm gonna help you i can't
help you with the attitude
but i can help you with the hard dick
blue chew
it's the first chewable dick pill same
fda approved active
ingredients as viagra and cialis this is
the [__]
you buy from some [__] bum at a
[__] liquor store
and next thing you know your hand going
your hand goes numb while you're trying
to whack off
blue chew is prescribed online by
licensed physicians
so you don't have to go to the doctor's
office or wait in line at a pharmacy
right now they got a special offer for
the joint family you ready
grab a pen visit blue chew dot com
that's blue b l u e c
dot com and your first shipment is free
when you press and code joey
just pay the five dollars for shipping
and again that's blue
like the color of that vein in your dick
when you show up at a house
and play the bongos on a [__] head
bluetooth.com
use code joey and thank and i want to
thank them for continuing
to sponsor the joint the joint is also
brought to you by
stamps.com listen i've been with
stamps.com for close to 10 years now
what thing you learned in 2020 is that
the internet is even more often than
what we thought
you could do everything on there
groceries
movies doctor visits and of course going
to the post office online
with stamps.com they save you time
money energy you know stamp.coms allow
businesses of all sizes to do all their
mailing and shipping
right from their computer no need to
leave their home or office
that's it they pick they pick them right
up here they save small businesses
thousands of hours and tons of money and
now
they can do the same for you my my wife
uses them to send out sweatshirts and
whatnot
tremendous you put them out right out
the mailman picks them up
it's that easy guys stamps.com
is a no-brainer especially now because
i'm saving you time
money and [__] i'm not i'm not i'm
keeping you healthy
make 2021 the year that you stop wasting
time
going to the post office go to
stamps.com instead
there's no risk with my code joey you're
going to get a special offer that
includes
a four-week trial plus free postage and
a digital scale
no long-term commitments or contracts
it's easy
go to stamps.com click on the microphone
at the top of the home page
and press in joey j-o-e-y that's
stamps.com
prestonjoey and never go to a post
office again
i want to thank stamps.com i want to
thank draftkings
i want to thank bluechu now let's get
this [__] party started
who's better than you nobody
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
what's happening you bad [__]
it's thursday
the 14th of january we're always [__]
almost mid month already
i'm looking good i'm feeling good thank
you for all the well wishes
the surgery went great uh physical
therapy that's a different story
my buttocks are sore you understand me
you're looking at me like joey
what are you talking about your buttocks
i saw well let's say you get raped by
five dudes your [__] is sore right
my buttocks are sore i have nothing
wrong with my [__]
it's my buttocks my buttocks i am 58
years old
and my buttocks have never been [__]
sore before
in their life do you understand me so
there's a problem right now
i know i must sound a little gay to you
guys right now by even saying that
you've never
any of you guys nobody has ever came up
to you and said you know what
my buttocks hurt today well
buttocks [__] hurt today [__]
i tell you that much
but everything is going great i took my
first uh post-surgical [__]
i almost fainted in the bathroom and the
fudge was coming out of my ass
and then once it stopped it wouldn't
stop i've been trying to [__] for three
[__] days
once they start shooting you with the
ladders and vicodins and liquid
milkshakes and
voodoo mixes that [__] your stomach up
yeah the pain goes away
but in a couple days you're gonna have
to pay for that [__] pain i paid for
it today
because it took me four days to [__] it
was like i'm a it was like i was a
snitch
you had to smack me 10 times smack me
twice to talk and 20 times to shut the
[__] up
i couldn't stop [__] i must have
took four uncontrollable [__]
tremendous shits
but that means the surgery was a success
you understand me i got all that [__]
toxin i mean all that mumbo jumbo
and it happened after you know why it
happened because when the
physical therapist came we were just
walking in here and i go let's take a
walk outside and i made her walk
up she's like where are we going she's
filipino sweetheart of a lady
she goes where we go i go we going up
the sun is out let's get some vitamin d
everybody needs some vitamin d
and i had my little old man stroller
just going jack stone to the gills
get a little vitamin d doing my thing
and uh
it was great so now i got physical
therapy tomorrow
and physical therapy on sunday i get the
stitches taken out on [__]
monday
and with all of then i switch
physical therapies i drive to a physical
therapist one of the kids i grew up with
is tremendous down here
and then uh hopefully by then i'll be
lifting some weights lightly and then
hopefully by then
we're on stage training for the [__]
summer that's the plan stan
did a little writing in the book today
did a little writing in the book
yesterday
uh i already ran into my first snag even
though i outlined it even though i
outlined it i wrote
two months two paragraphs too much it
took my chin down
for a couple hours and i said [__] it
erase it and write it again that's what
i did
and i'm better now that's what happened
but i want to talk to you about a few
things and i'll get you out of here i
know it's thursday you're like joey who
drops a podcast on thursday
my mind is on different things [__] it
it's thursday i want to slow you down a
little bit
bill bird drop says morning monday
morning podcast on thursday or whatever
thursday morning podcast on thursday
so [__] it we're not really off the grid
we're just a little late you know what
i'm saying
but i want to talk to you about
something just to get out there and get
it on the air and the whole [__] deal
because i don't know if you people
understand the feeling
i don't know if you understand feelings
and i don't know if you've ever thought
about
somebody else's feelings when
something's going on
i got locked up in 88 i got out in 89
no big deal it didn't kill me i didn't
get raped i had a good time in prison i
found out who
and what i was made of and what i didn't
want to do anymore
was go back to prison oh that's great
but something happens when you come out
of prison
okay you your mental takes over you a
certain way and it starts with your mind
playing stricts on you
you know uh i told you i told you guys i
got like that semi heart attack on the
21st of august
but i didn't go to the doctor my my
chest cave hurt for a few days
whatever uh yeah it was a [__] mild
heart attack you know
i don't know what it's got to do with
this [__] but uh for a few days after
that i had like residual pain and
whatever i didn't know what was going on
once the pain went away i was fine this
is what's going on now
i realized after the stress test and uh
echocardio i'm fine
i was just it was all in my mind your
mind has a weird way of playing with you
when i went to get the uh evaluation on
my
right knee the doctor goes the weird
thing is your left knee is a worse
shape as soon as i walked out of the
doctor i went to the car the left knee
started hurting
that's what your mind does to your mind
plays drinks on you how many years check
your temperature eight times a day
during covert because you feel something
you know your mind
plays tricks on you one of the things
your mind
plays tricks on you is that it let's
it it makes you think me
joe diaz that everybody in this room
knows i just got out of prison
when you walk into a supermarket it
makes me
think that everybody in that supermarket
found out
i went to prison it's just this weird
little thing that you have for a few
months
and it feels terrible now you're talking
to a guy
who didn't really get i don't give a
[__] what people got to say about me
if you don't have the balls to say it to
my face then what good is it right or
wrong so
it didn't really bother me as much as it
would bought but i i
would say wow it doesn't bother me as
much
but there's people that had just been to
prison the first time i wonder how it
bothers them
you know and uh
it's not your mind after a while then
you start to feel it
uh i gotta i got out of uh
for me it was more during county jail
when i got arrested for the
actual robbery and i sat a month in jail
one newspaper two newspaper articles
came out about the incident one came out
the wednesday after the tuesday but it
didn't have my name on it and then one
came out
maybe a week later with that the third
party had been arrested his name was
joey diaz he got charged whatever he got
charged with
in my mind that boulder paper was the
new york times
so do you understand what i'm trying to
say to you just it just [__] me to
pieces
and
i went uh nobody would hire me you know
the
bill crowd subaru won't hire me nobody
would hire me
but this one guy named bob wheeler hired
me he was from detroit michigan from
dearborn
tough white dude he just liked the way i
sell
he basically trained me what had bill
crowd subaru
how to be a [__] killer so he had
gone to a store in longmont colorado
and since nobody else would hire me in
the boulder area
he hired me he got me a demo to get
there every day
he did everything i could everything i
could i will never forget him even
though he's lost gone his
children still messaged me on facebook
from time to time
great kids i knew he was going to raise
great kids because he was a great guy
himself
but let me tell you some circumstances
that happened you know while i was
working from
there were white dudes in the ford store
whatever they sold at that time we sold
a long run subaru nissan and something
else
there were guys in a nissan store that
wouldn't come over to the subaru store
because i was working there no i hadn't
done anything that bad
these are the same people that were
snorting coke buying coke from the same
dealers and everything
but they wouldn't come over here because
they were offended that i had
gotten a job there i don't know if you
guys ever knew about this but let's go
through it
and it's got a great payday to the end
of this so
he just got a lot of heat every day you
know
and he would tell him want to go [__]
himself that's my dog joey
and i ended up working there for 30 days
and i tell you what my mind was so
confused with the court case and
everything else that was going on
i wasn't the same student i wasn't the
salesman that i was
it was like what happened to me after
the move here i wasn't the same comic i
wasn't the same podcaster i wasn't
i wasn't the same a lot of things and
after 30 days he pulled me aside he's
like look at the owners they're getting
a lot of grief
i'm gonna give you a month's salary you
know
take some time to yourself go figure
something else out
you know and he took really good care of
me financially and
he sold my girlfriend a car it cost and
that was the only car i sold i talked to
my girlfriend i got a fr uh
give me it was a 100 deal
and you know he called me every day
check on me how was i doing what was
going on and then he decided to get
married
and he invited me to the wedding
and uh after a few weeks or something
i just heard rumblings that
a lot of people had told them if i was
going to the wedding
they weren't going to the wedding and do
you know what his answer was
then go [__] yourself don't even give me
a [__] gift
you know and by this time i'd gotten up
and he was still getting heat about me
and i'll never forget that i went to him
like a man and i go
jim i'm pissing off like six or seven
people
over a wedding i i don't want to do that
you know let me just give you an
envelope
we're best friends you and i both know
that i love you and i love your wife
i love your son the bump he already had
the bump
and he goes no that's not all right
he goes you did a crime
you reported to the judge
and you did your time you
did what you had to do for society to
come clean
and in my book and this guy was a white
dude he had never been to jail this
wasn't what this guy was this guy was
this guy wasn't a criminal he was a
regular normal guy just like you guys
nice people go to work month to month
he told me that he goes you paid your
due to society
now it's your job to become a
contributing member to society
so don't be ashamed about them they're
the ones that have a problem
you don't have a problem you did what
you were supposed to do
so what you [__] up what they never
[__] up he goes now they [__] up
with me
because they can never talk to me again
he goes don't ever be a [__] shamed
about what you did
you did it you did your time and you
moved the [__] out
now why are we talking about this joy
why are we going through this [__]
beat i'm going to tell you why because
till this day
from time to time i still remember how i
felt
those couple of months when people
didn't understand that what i'd done
with a mistake i mean
i had people turn their back on me that
i went to the houses to eat i played
with their children
they knew what i was about i could
understand listen when we started the
church
i came right out and told you about the
kidnapping because i didn't want you to
find out about it three years in
i wanted you to find out from the
beginning so you knew who the [__] i was
sort of be no misunderstandings i'm not
here to [__] nobody i don't give a
[__] about what your opinion is
i don't know what your life is and you
don't know what my life is so who the
[__] are we to
criticize one another i just said it to
get it out of the way
and i talked about all my other crimes
to get them out of the way as a
matter of fact and some of them are
horrific crimes
and we made them funny you know we made
them a little funny or whatever
am i supposed to still feel guilty no
no i did it i moved on and here we are
today in 2021
now i'll never forget how i felt those
few months though
that these were people that broke bread
with me these were people that i'd see
at barbecues
these are people that see around boulder
and talk to
and it was really because after that i
started calculating okay
how many other people are not going to
talk to me and who is going to talk to
me
and it was very interesting who stayed
my best friend
and who went away and it was i was
completely wrong on who was going to
stand who was going to leave
so how's that for you i had no [__]
idea who my friends were
it didn't matter to me everything worked
out i got them to stand up blah blah
blah blah blah
and boom we moved the [__] on uh but i
never forgot
i never forgot about this this last
march uh
let's just say january some girl decides
to get up one day
and contact the newspaper
and say that
some guy was sending her text messages
and she was underage or whatever
and it sparked articles and newspapers
and
it sparked artrage amongst the comedy
community and that's fine
it was the initial hit you know
um yesterday my man uh
sarah z siren z he
said what's his name cool [__]
love him to death
makes me laugh uh even though sometimes
he talks [__] about me i still laugh
because
what he's saying is with a smile on his
face he has no hatred in his heart
he's just reporting what he said and but
yesterday he put up a video
that i uh would have knocked down
crystalia which it was put up by a
producer to get hits
i did not call out dalia i did not
say anything wrong about dalia what i
said was
who i was keeping in touch with in la
still who i'm still friends with bert
tom today i talked to eddie bravo he was
the funniest
he goes joey i saw the pictures of your
stitches in the paper and
the internet he goes how long was the
surgery i go four hours he goes that's a
lot of [__] stitches
he goes were you up for it i go oh yeah
yeah they gave me a gram of coke
and i [__] talked it out with the
doctor i told him what the cut what not
to kind of oh yeah eddie
they put me to [__] bed when did they
leave me awake like that
for [__] 100 stitches yeah just to
give my grandma coke go work out the
rest i'm just sitting there
move that toe you know what the [__] is
wrong with people
i told everybody i talked to eddie i
talked to lee
and i checked him with the leah from
time to time and the reason why i
checked with leah from time to time
is now i'm gonna tell you my story and
you could decide on what the [__] you
want to do with it
i went back to the store in 2013.
i had never met crystalia before that i
had seen him a couple of times
at the life factory with dane cook and
uh the improv
[__] very funny very energetic
always had two broadway all right not
one
but two loved it good looking girls
you know they looked of age i you know i
don't know
what age looks like but these girls
looked of age they were drinking
whatever you know
uh over the years we became tighter at
the store you know i'd see him at the
store
i'd have to follow him was like
following a [__] hurricane
uh but i did it i didn't give a [__]
sometimes i hate a bag of [__]
but i always talked to him i always gave
him love i always uh
winked at him before i went on stage i
never did a lunch with him
i never had a dinner with him but while
we were at the comedy store together we
did talk and we had some interesting
conversations about touring and whatnot
and once he got his girlfriend he
stopped bringing girls around
so i would see him like go come here for
a second what are we [__] switching
governments
what did you become gay all of a sudden
where's the broads every night that was
part of me going down there to see the
two broads deleo was going to show up
with it was [__] great
once he got the girlfriend he fell in
love he got serious
and there wasn't two broads anymore so i
didn't see nothing for three or four
years two
three years and all of a sudden i'm
seeing this this friend who i call a
friend of mine getting bombarded with
all this [__]
but i also saw the next day when he got
the
other end of the emails to protect
themselves and whatnot
that people didn't want to see him he
was all he had already been
convicted judged and executioned
by a bunch of people that had the power
not even to do that
you don't have the power to do that now
let's take
like i said before on this podcast a
thousand times
let's take our boy ron jeremy
i know ron jeremy is a porno guy do i
watch pornos no i worked a
commander video and captain video in
aspen in 83 and 84 and people that had
had two rows of a porno section
and women and guys always come in and
say if they've had iran jeremy tapes
and one day i finally threw them in them
like who's this [__] greasy bastard
i said that's all i knew around jeremy
and one day i moved to l.a and i saw him
at bank of america
did i run up to him and say hello no i
don't give a [__]
he's probably got [__] uh sticky
hands from sperm and [__]
dirty [__] and [__] yeah i don't know
nobody i don't say hello to the guy
then i start seeing him at the [__]
store okay and he says hello goodbye how
you doing whatever
i don't see him again then one day i do
a podcast with the pimp
from vegas and he shows up with him and
he plays the harmonica and
i got a kick out of him i got a kick out
of ron jeremy i didn't know what his
life was about and
it's not like i took a picture i need to
take a picture and
post it no i just knew ron jeremy he was
a nice guy and
that's it and when one day i'm reading
about all these allegations against
brian against you know uh chris against
you know everybody in their mother
and uh ron jeremy gets arrested for rape
and they got him and i didn't know
anything about ron
but again from going to jiu jitsu i have
two dear jiu jitsu friends
that are involved in the porno business
so i asked them
around jeremy and boy did they have a
mouthful
to tell me and you know what after about
a week i made a constant decision
i didn't want any problems no company no
sponsor told me i did it
because i'm not comfortable with rape i
took the podcast that he was on down
it wasn't lee it wasn't draftkings
it wasn't the cbd lion i did it
i did it because it's rape okay it's a
complete different [__] thing
now i got gallon was on my podcast a few
times
did he get convicted of rape no if you
guys are hating them already as a rapist
i don't see the conviction i don't see
the paperwork i don't see [__]
anything
and from my side i got to see something
you know i don't know what's going on
there i haven't heard from
brian in three weeks i've spoken to sam
and he keeps me
going with what's going on in la right
now
i do check in with chris you know we
we spoke christmas week we spoke new
year's
and new year's i unleashed i said
brother that's it it's enough for
[__] weight you know
it's enough of a way aren't you sick and
just standing there and having people
point their fingers at you
you're my brother i hate to see you
[__] hurt start this podcast
tell your story that's what i said i
said tell your story
and start this podcast and the quicker
you tell the story and the quicker you
start this podcast
it's going to take you six months to a
year it took louis ck a couple years to
get his footing back
you know i'm not mad at louis ck he took
his dick out and showed it to a couple
of [__] broads what are you doing for
me i wasn't in the room
and neither were you you know
when did you read any of these brian
callum
were you there when brian raped anybody
or supposedly forced himself on these
women
were you me neither you know as far as
brian collins com
crystal is concerned i have a kid
i have a wife and what sixty percent of
my best friends
are women from felicia to kate quigley
to lisa tizio to lisa gallo all over the
place i have girls out of my friends
here
that were best friends i'm not i'm i'm
not
i wouldn't be happy with somebody
texting them when they were under age
but there is a thing called a mistake
and i know crystal here
i know chris i know what it where his
heart is you know
and i can tell you that this doesn't
sound like the chris i know
so because of that reason was why i was
applauding them and why i was trying to
give him a lift
and let's pretend let's pretend for the
sake of argument
that chris did send
a [__] tweet to a [__] girl
guys
there's a lot of crazy people on the
internet
there's a lot of crazy women on that
internet that have a lot of [__] to say
i'm 58 and i look at it and go whoa
that's a little too real for
me but i've seen seeing some [__] on the
internet from some young girls
that are just crazy we all have we don't
know what a 16 year old girl looks like
or 17 year old girl or 18 [__] year
old girl
i know for a fact the one of the [__]
happiest days of my life was when i read
that rae dong-chang admitted that she
[__]
mick jagger when she was 15 or 16 and
was not mad at him
you know felicia used to have a friend i
forget what her name was real pretty
girl
and she used to tell me stories about
her growing up in the valley
and walking down laurel canyon to the
clubs and being 15 and 16
and hooking up with [__] musicians
and nobody was
throwing nobody under the bus again
that's not my daughter that's not
what i'm raising to be but this was
something that was
you know it's a 16 year old girl a guy
smiles at her
she gets attention whatever i don't
think it's right i don't agree with it
but again i don't think crystalline is
one of these guys
and that's just me talking on here and i
may be a criminal
and i may be a lot of things but you
guys got to remember something i spent
time in jail
i spent time around murderers i spent
time around bank robbers
i spent time around rapists i spent time
around child molesters i did not hang
with them
i got to look at them and i got to study
them like an animal or a [__]
in a [__] circus you know whenever
you go to a zoo and you sit down and you
stop
and you look at the whole [__]
giraffe exhibit
and you see that maybe the one giraffe
might have a teddy bear or whatever
you know i got to look at all these guys
every day
and i and there's a couple things i
could tell you from that
[__] thing crystalia didn't do
anything wrong
and ralphie may is not a rapist when
somebody accused ralphie mayer rape i
i went off the [__] deep end because
i know a rapist
the rapist has a different breed beat
than a crackhead
has a different beat than what i was a
[__] robber
i was a plain day robber a burglar a
[__]
you know so they all have a different
beat
so i know the beat of a rapist i know
the beat of a guy that
that really indulges in little [__]
girls
you know you don't know what goes out
there in hollywood
you don't know the girls that just go
out there and don't know you know i
watched
i saw [__] uh paris hilton on [__]
letterman
telling stories how she used to sneak
off out of her window when she was 15 in
new york
to go out and see [__] men those
[__] should be shot now
they knew she was 15 but that's not what
i'm here to do
i'm just trying to explain to you what i
see saw happen to a friend
that this didn't deserve to happen you
want to kick them off the [__] movie
coming off the [__] movie you wanted
to kick them off
a tv show whatever kick them off the tv
show
but this was not warranted by this guy
this guy came back
this guy came back crystalia and tried
to show you
other tweets that he had received but
nobody wanted to see them
you guys didn't give them a chance to
protect themselves
why would you like if that was you would
you like that if i didn't give you your
chance to open up your mouth
and say hey this is what really [__]
happened as soon as they [__] came
at me with some [__] about 20 years
ago i opened up my [__] mouth
you ain't taking it away from me i work
too hard for this you [__] dummies
you're worried about a girl who sucked
my dick but you don't give a [__]
about a guy that was in the trunk of a
car go [__] yourself
your priorities are all [__] wrong if
you hit me up tomorrow and say i'm not
listening to you because you kidnapped
the guy in 88
i'd accept that but don't say to me that
oh joe rogan laughed at your joke so
he's guilty really
there was just a bunch of stupidity at
that time that we look back on now and
you could address and go what the [__]
were these people talking about
what were they talking about
yeah so how the [__] are you gonna
[__] sit there
and be mad at whatever the [__] listen
chris delia
if you're watching this brother i love
you i got your back
it's time for you to [__] start your
little podcast tell your stories
let them throw eggs at you let them
throw eggs at you let them do whatever
the [__] they want
and you're going to go through it and
then you're going to win because you're
going to hold your [__] ground
in this business now you got to hold
your ground they're going to come after
you every week for something you did
82 years ago and i'm not going to go for
it neither of you
you wouldn't like it if it happened to
you if somebody came after you with an
action you did
20 30 [__] years ago so when cyan
said that the other day
a lot of people in the comments said i
don't know what you're thinking
joey's giving him light you know and he
we laughed we giggled
i didn't leave a comment but that's the
truth brother
i was just trying to give him [__]
light i don't like what's been done to
him
and you know what the l.a times is one
thing
you know i understand hollywood movies
i understand sponsors on a podcast
but when your own are turning you into
the [__] wolves
that's what pisses me the [__] off
that's when i
that this and every time i see somebody
make a remark towards
chris or something i send them a message
hey man how you holding up
how you keeping your chin up don't
[__] listen to those [__] guys
they're all to have their heyday this is
part of being a friend
this is what friendship entails you got
to pick a side sometimes
you got to pick a [__] side if he was
to stab four people and kill a
grandmother do you think i'd be checking
up on him
no but this is a story of he said she
said
nobody real uh there's one world who
said he took his dick out in cleveland
whatever
crystal is a good dude you know what i'm
saying he's a very handsome dude
there's a lot of things he doesn't need
to do to attract [__] women i'm not
calling them liars i'm not saying
nothing
i'm just telling you from all the facts
i've gathered as a human being
as a criminal and as a comic
crystalline is okay by my eyes so you
guys want to keep [__] throwing
[__] sand on them and burying them
[__] you what do you want me to tell
them to go and hide
[__] you you don't hide from [__]
nobody
if we did it we did it we stand up and
we tell our explanation
and why we did it and that's it if you
don't like it go [__] yourself
if you can live with it you live it
listen let me tell you a very [__]
story here very special story okay i
love animals
i don't know when i was about four i
became inaudible animals and then when i
was about six i saw one throw a beat on
a guy
faded an animal and i got the whole
under culture of the cuban
dogs why you don't have dogs in cuba
because they're they're protected by
saint lazaro and all this [__] and
that's all great and dandy but i saw an
abused dog once i saw some kids when i
was a kid
like [__] a dog that was burnt and i
remember how my stomach
felt and i remember that between you and
i
i was too much of a [__] to go back and
hit him with a head with a [__] brick
but thinking about it today in the third
grade this happened
in 1973 in new york city like on
riverside drive if i would have the
balls i had today
i should have hit those kids with a
brick in the head and [__] smash
their heads
for lighting this dog's tail on fire or
some [__] i was
so pissed at myself that night so i've
never been happy on dog
cat abuse animal beef listen i get it i
get it that you buy a dog
and also when your wife gets pregnant
and she's scared of that breed a dog
you got to get rid of him i i get all
that and you take them down to a shelter
i don't get you leaving them on a post
and leaving them outside i don't get you
[__] tying them to some [__]
street or moving
and leaving them in the backyard that's
not cool in my world and that's animal
abuse
and in my neighborhood that's a [__]
uh those uh charges to get beat up
like people in my neighbor would beat
you up for that not me
i just mind my business but what i'm
trying to say to you is
when i was a kid i saw all these guys
burn that dog and i heard him cry
and till this day you know i'm a [__]
piece of [__]
for not going back and hitting one of
those kids in the head with a [__]
brick but
that's not the story the story was 10
years ago
20 years ago 15 years ago michael vick
gets in trouble
for the [__] dogs okay
right away i go [__] ass silent about
michael vick
it's dogs there's no excuse i read a few
of the articles there's no [__]
excuse
but i wanted to see i wanted to see the
hand he was gonna play
you know and he took his lumps
he took his salary loss he paid his
fines
he did his time and he talks to people
now about
dog fighting and the dangers of and he
inspires and whatnot
now what am i supposed to do
what is a guy like me supposed to do do
i get on facebook and twitter and say
[__] michael vick don't let him get into
the hall of fame
because 10 years ago he i read what he
did he electrocuted the dogs i read
drowned them i read all that stuff but
now what is
where does this put me
so i really really really had to think
about this like where does this put me
as a human being
am i going to be a hypocrite and sign
this petition
and not let him make the hall of fame
let me just think about this
let me just think about this and i
prayed on it and i thought about it
believe it or not
and it's like how can i not because a
crime is a crime
rape kidnapping dog abuse child abuse
a crime is a crime the extent of a crime
is you know however you consider it but
in my world the crime is a [__] crime
okay
uh killing dogs you know this is america
white people with sandals love dead dogs
you're going under the prison for a
while
um i was mad at
michael rick you know as a personal per
you know not that i would state it or
whatever
but he did his time he paid his fines
um you know i haven't heard any more
involvement with [__] dogs or michael
vick
you know so in my heart
because i was forgiven
by people after i did what i did what i
did was know
yeah we goof around in here haha it's a
joke
but what i did was also a crime so how
can i not forgive
michael vick on a personal level
if people forgave me and most
importantly i forgave myself
so what i did was i started watching
whatever michael vick
you know does like the nfl network or
something for somebody once a while
and i just started watching him i
started looking at his eyes and watching
him and you know what man
he was a young kid with an old one down
they threw a ton of money on him
you know it's like taking a 25 year old
kid in hollywood
and throwing a bunch of money off off to
off to him and let's see where this goes
you know for some people it's drugs for
some people it's
you know charlie sheen [__] 20
hookers and porno girls
for [__] michael vick it was dog
fighting and
that was his mistake you know i hope
he's not doing it anymore but
i was forced to forgive michael vick why
because i was forgiven
how can i forgive everybody else i was
on mike tyson's podcast another guy that
got convicted or raped
okay convicted of rape you ever see mike
tyson on the [__] plane
it's like a party you ever see mike
tyson walk through an airport
everybody loves him because everybody
felt it was a sham of a [__] call
this rape
you know i've heard different stories
about the rape and whatnot
they don't sound they don't sound that
damaging to me it's not going to make me
hate
mike tyson or dislike mike tyson
i became friends with mike tyson maybe
three four years ago
talking little by little i watched all
his footage
uh you're gonna [__] suck my dick i'm
gonna eat you
when he was yelling at the white
announcer what do you think of the
things i say
you know he's from brooklyn i'm from new
york city jersey i'm i'm the same
[__]
type of madman i say some crazy [__] too
i have anger and
issues in my heart you know i was
talking a few weeks ago at home 58
and that kid saved me because by now
with a shot like 20 you [__] l.a cox
up this
but i can't do that i can't do that i
got responsibilities for my daughter
i got responsibilities myself and to you
guys
so for me to walk the walk i got to [__]
for me to talk to talk
i got to walk the walk so i forgave
michael vick
and now i feel a lot better about it i
don't even know michael vick
i've never even met michael vick that
doesn't matter
i had to use it as how am i living my
life
who the [__] am i whatever if you don't
like michael vick switch them
michael victims on your channel switch
them
if not then don't [__] switch them
and shut the [__] up
if you're still mad at michael vick you
never committed a crime
everybody talks about being a christian
and forgiveness
where's your forgiveness where's your
forgiveness
i don't expect you to forgive harvey
weinstein i ain't forgetting
and i ain't forgiving [__] the yoga
guy the hot yoga guy whatever
kishner with his stinky [__] hummus
balls
making stupid white girl suck this dick
to learn [__] downward dog
how [__] are you you know i'm not
mad at these f i mean i am mad at these
[__] guys they have nothing to do
with me
they have nothing to do with my world
but i also have to look at that
felonious side
and i was a felon at one time and how
much how many breaks did people give me
i still remember all the people that
didn't give me braces i was a felony
shame on them shame on them they didn't
really get to know me
you know like i said if i came out here
and go welcome to the pilot uncle joey's
joint i just got out of prison for doing
kidnapping i'm giving you the
opportunity right there
to either turn me on or keep me the [__]
on what do you want to do you don't
like me you like me you don't like me
keep me on or turn me the [__] off
if from there you like me then we're all
the way in don't come back at me three
years from now go
yeah but you kept not the guy you knew
that in the [__] beginning stupid
that's why i couldn't believe that they
came up with that thing it's like that
kid a couple weeks ago that was robbing
me on youtube
so you're making copies you're going to
producers you're calling people
you're my biggest fan i tell you you
can't rob me no more now you got
secret videos of us doing coke in the
studio in 2016.
[Laughter]
anyway i don't know what that means
that's the force of destiny
that's what that means who the [__] am i
kidding i just i used to always know
i used to also know how to say that in
german but it's been a while since i
watched that episode
of [__] uh the odd couple but as i
was saying before
yeah i still talk to dalia
and i'll still talk to callum if he
calls me until
you come up with that [__] guilty
plea on any of my [__] friends
or you come up and you press charges you
have [__] charges
then i'll start looking into the case
until then
i'm not believing you i know these
people i don't know you
i don't know you you could have came out
anywhere and opened your mouth and tried
to say this guy
raped you 20 [__] years ago 20 years
ago
so in my world listen i always have to
give people a second chance
because i was given a second chance and
how would that
what type of person would it make me be
if i didn't learn to give people a
second chance or
to even come to you people to give
somebody a second chance of throwing a
dial on them
because i'm telling you this was not
done
correctly and i asked questions you know
let's be honest with each other three
four weeks after it all went down
uh i knew how he was feeling why because
i had been there
i reached out to him and i said
come by the office let's sit outside
i didn't call him to get a podcast out
of him
i didn't call him to get the the scoop
review because i
i just wanted to talk to him man i
wanted to talk to him because where i
come from
here it is plain and simple if you kill
somebody
come to me tell me a story tell me the
truth
don't miss a detail don't miss a detail
and i got your back 150 percent
you know what chris talia did he came
over he spoke to me
and he didn't miss a detail
i shook his hand i gave him a hug i
think i seen him once again after that
never asked him about a podcast never
said nothing
i just wanted to rap with him just
wanted to rap with him
just to see where he was at i could tell
from there
and i could tell where the kid was that
he was broken-hearted
and he's not worried about money he
didn't care about money
he was broken-hearted because
three-quarters of the [__] they were
saying was [__]
and the other quarter of the heart that
he was brokenhearted about was
how his friends turned on him you know
a lot of people turned on me when i
[__] got in trouble with velo a lot
of people have turned on me in their
lives
and you know what at the end of the day
sometimes i'm happy they did
i'm happy and that's why i told them be
happy
you didn't want them around anyway i'm
happy they turned on them
and every other day i turn on the
computer to somebody else [__]
busting his balls about something and
i'm happy
i'm happy that you you guys get to see
what hollywood is about
and what people are about and you know
and now you get to see what i'm about
i'm an old school a dog unless i see the
blue paperwork
with the charges i don't give a [__]
what you got to say
well what you're going to tell me about
1983 or 1985
or we were in acting class in 93 and you
didn't decide to call the cops then
and then you took his movie after he
gave you a movie
ah you know
you know what i'm saying it's like my
boy the one that broke into the [__]
uh white house that looked like the
younger bunga man
and his mother yeah he's not eating
because they have no organic food uh
hello
once you broke the law you got no rights
you gotta eat
dog [__] with [__] you gotta eat if they
give you a dog [__] po boy
that's what you're eating you know why i
don't wanna go back to jail because i
ain't gonna see that sleep apnea for
three weeks
that sleep apnea machine they don't give
a [__] about so if you walk into prison
like hi
here's my sleep apnea machine they're
gonna go throw that in the [__]
garbage
we don't give a [__] about your sleep
happy machine you should've thought
about your sleep apnea machine before
you walked up those [__] white house
capital steps
or before you put that dude in the trunk
of a car or before you sold coke
or before you [__] stabbed your wife
or before you did any of those things
you should have thought about your
organic diet behind jail so he's not
eating for five days
because then it's an organic diet i
don't even think there's vegan
[__] diets in jail yet
i know what some of the nicer ones you
know
they'll give you a banana a carrot or
something like that but i don't think
they're even playing with the vegans
once you go to prison you lose all that
[__] there's some prisons you don't even
get a pillow at
you don't even get a pillow out you just
got a sheet of paper it's a cold [__]
bed
and all night you're on your [__] arm
and every 20 minutes you got to switch
[__] arms
because your shoulders get [__] tight
and this guy's worried about organic
food
if you were such a tough guy you
wouldn't be eating [__] organic food
anyway [__] nut breaking into the
[__] white house
then your mom is calling three weeks
later he's not eating who gives a [__]
he should have thought about that before
they don't serve [__] smoothies in
prison [__]
just sperm spoolies trust me you'll love
those
if if you like a [__] uh
the brazilian bulls wait do you take
[__] fruit flavored sperm in prison
the brothers give that out the nice
white kids tremendous
[__] organic food in prison are you
[__] [__]
this is the [__] that so you wanted to
commit a crime
and now you're mad because they don't
have organ what do you think they got
for breakfast croissants in prison
you got a buttered roll with an ant
going through it that's it and you eat
it and you bite the ant because you
don't know what you're gonna eat again
you bite that out because that ad is
protein you understand what i'm trying
to say to you [__]
but but you can believe the times we're
in he's he's
he's not eating because because he's
he's he needs an organic diet i'm like
what the [__] are people thinking
anymore
it's it's getting ugly out there guys
but with this and that we said what we
came to [__] say today on a [__]
thursday morning i'm not here to take up
your whole morning
i just want to talk to you about uh my
situation with the surgery listen guys
i did this surgery for my daughter so i
could walk better in the years to come
you know we could live as a [__]
family and uh
i thought we would take this week off i
really i didn't want to say anything it
was gonna be
day to day with mike but you know what
man [__] that
i knew that you guys needed me i knew
that you guys depend on me
if you're on patreon i gave you an extra
joey diaz project this week
just out of respect for covering for the
[__] new year's thing
somebody sent me the tape we found the
[__]
the link from new year's it's there but
it's all [__] up so i don't know i
tried to send it to you
we could do something on i was do some
chinese [__] video on there for you
of me just let you know but it was two
weeks ago i'll give you another surprise
this weekend you never know
but yeah i'm the patreon i gave you uh
uncle joey's project today just a little
gift just a little thank you for
understanding
and for everybody else i'll take care of
you my way also
i don't want you to [__] think i'm
beating you here for
for nothing i'm pumping out content
every day and i'm here for you like i
said on my
joey diaz project the emails have gotten
so much better so i know
your lives have gotten better my life
has gotten better my stress levels have
gotten down
my eyes have opened a little more i know
where i'm gonna be
the emails have gotten a lot better guys
i'm so happy you're doing well
you know october november i was getting
nothing but [__] bad emails and i was
answering them all
trying to you know take the steps with
you but we're here and i gotta tell you
it's the second week of january
and i've been getting emails lately that
are clean nobody's
i mean i'm getting like one out of eight
emails it was
eight out of eight we're all bad now i'm
getting one out of eight
you know i'm feeling better my dad's
getting healthy my mom's covered went
away
so thank you guys thank you for paying
attention
thank you for writing the journals thank
you for uh
you know making your goals for 2021
these are all gonna come in
to help you okay uh like i said no
disrespect my man zion z
i love you to death i'd love to smoke a
joint with you someday
i think you're a blast i love your
giggle under when you
when you say [__] about people you have
that little giggle and [__]
and i [__] love it let me know in the
comments yeah let me know
below in the comments that lets me know
that
you have no malice in your heart you're
doing a great job
and you got 100 support from me uh
he lives off tips on that so give him a
tip
on that give him a 10 give him a 20.
he's got some interesting stuff to say
but uh
that's it and that's that like i said
i'm sorry about the surgical week
i'm a lot better than what i thought i
would be to be honest with you
and uh thank you for all the love and
support
i want to thank draftkings this week i
want to thank stamps.com
i want to thank cbd lion
i want to thank zip recruiter i want to
thank blue chew
i want to thank ahn and all my sponsors
and i want to thank you guys for always
having our backs
thank you very much see you monday nice
and early
tip top magoo ready to go i love you
guys thank you
all right thank you again for listening
on a thursday i'm sorry about this
weekend
i had the [__] in the surgery and it
threw the whole week off but you know
every day i'm getting stronger and
better thank you for all the well wishes
and uh
you guys brought me back on your own
with the love but before we leave
i want to talk to you a little bit about
stamps.com tremendous my wife has been
with them for 20 years 10 years whatever
the [__] 10 years
listen for t-shirts cups they're solid
you call the mailman you tell you leave
the packages outside
right by the mailbox and the mailman
picks it up for you
it's that easy one thing we learned in
is that the internet is [__] awesome
it's more awesome than we ever thought
you could order everything on there and
of course you could go to the post
office online
with stamps.com stamps.com allows
businesses of all sizes
to do all their mailing and shipping
right from their computer no need to
leave the house or office
or home office they've saved small
businesses thousands of hours
and tons of gears and now you can save
them too listen
my wife and i are the only things around
we got the kid we don't have time to be
going to post office back and forth
standing on lines
she prints all the labels right there
the shipping
i mean it's tremendous if you're not
working with stamps.com
you're wasting a ton of time because
like i said they bring the post office
to you to you skip the line
you print the postage 24 7. any letter
any size package going anywhere in the
world
right from your couch and the best part
here it is
the mailman will come and pick it up
like i told you you also get
great discounts you get five cents off
every first class stamp
and up to 40 percent off priority males
plus save up to 62
on ups rates guys stamps.com is a
no-brainer i'm telling you from the
heart
especially now i don't care what size
business you have you're going to save
time
and money so make 2021 the year you stop
wasting time going to the post office
and go to stamps.com instead there's no
risk
with my code joey and get a special
offer that includes
a five-week trial plus free postage and
digital scale
no long-term commitments or contracts
it's very easy just go to stamps.com
click on the microphone at the top of
the home page
and pressing joey and boom stamps.com is
yours you'll never go to the [__]
post office again
stamps.com is the way to go code joey
the joint is also brought to you by
today
thursday draftkings i got a tnt
doubleheaded tonight
i got two other games that got soft
lines and you're sitting there worried
about
the numbers are doubling in delaware who
gives the frenchman's [__]
the the numbers are doubling in your
[__] pocket
why because you're with draftkings
[__] sports are in full swings
there's no shortage of action like i
said we're gonna get you started tonight
on thursday night you're gonna make more
money this [__] weekend
with a parlay on thursday one college
game friday
and then you got the pros let me tell
you what happens on saturday with the
pros
draftkings has got you covered pick bet
any football game
that's got there's four football games
this weekend pick any of them
and you got 100 to one odds that's right
all you got to do is bet a dollar
on any football game this weekend for a
chance to win
100 bucks plus the basketball season is
tipped off and the lines are still soft
so head to the sportsbook app right now
draftkings app right now
to check out that daily odds boost and
if you haven't signed up yet
what the [__] are you waiting for now is
the time
download the draftking sports book app
today it's safe secure
reliable and guess what it's your
[__] money
deposit and withdrawal at your
convenience
download the top-rated draftking
sportsbook app now
use promo code joy when you sign up to
get 100 to one odds
on any football game this weekend that's
code joey for new players
to get a shot at a hundred to one odds
on any football action this weekend
and guess what by [__] after tomorrow
night's pal and friday night's action
your bank roll is gonna be on fire
you're gonna have some check over
saturday night
sucking your dick coven style you ever
got a covered [__] yet tremendous
they don't breathe out of their nose
they either [__] breathe out of their
mouth or they die
it's a beautiful weekend it's draftkings
type weekend
that and this is going on for a limited
time only a hundred to one so
here's the part the lawyers make me say
you got to be 21 old
new jersey indiana pennsylvania
tennessee colorado restrictions apply
see draftkings.com sportsbook for
details now
do we have a gambling problem there's
help 1-800 gambler
and if you're in indiana 1-809 with it
but if you're not the kiss of death
download the draftking sportsbook app
use code joey
and cash in on this deal this weekend
there i'm saving your money already
draftsma fuckingstamps.com and
draftkings there you go
now you could when you win from draft uh
kings you can mail your rent with
stamps.com who's better than joey
anyway it's the second week of january
you still got a limp dick
and goals to get [__] it's over you
know why because uncle joey showed up
with blue chew
it's all about a big dick in attitude
and after this [__] podcast you're
gonna have both those things covered
you're like joey what's blue chew it's
the first chewable dick pill
same fda approved tactical ingredients
as viagra
and cialis this isn't some [__]
funny pill you buy all [__] pablo at
the liquor store
and too much [__] later your left eye
won't stop twitching
it's not that type of party blue chewers
are prescribed online
by licensed physicians so you don't have
to go to the doctor's office
and wait in line at the pharmacy like a
putts and make eye contact with the girl
and now she knows you got limp dick you
don't need this aggravation
and it ships right to your door in a
discreet package nobody knows nothing
they think you're getting a [__]
envelope from some from grandma or
something
blue chew is even cheaper than the
pharmacy and you can take them anytime
day or night even on a full stomach
so right now i got a special offer for
the joint
visit bluetooth.com that's bluechew.com
and get your first shipment free you're
like joey it's the beginning of the year
yeah they're free
free that's how we start you're single
you ain't slinging dick your wife walks
around covering her face like she just
walked out of homicide you need that
go get bluetooth.com right now
it's blue again that's blue chew b-l-u-e
like the color of your dick once you hit
you before you hit you
eddie i listen i don't care if you're
gay let me tell you something if you're
gay you're going to be busting [__]
with this blue chew
so this is for you too why should i say
women you might hit some guy named
little pete in the head with your dick
that's that's not what i'm into but i
don't care what you're into
blue chew just want you to be happy so
go to bluetooth right now
use code joey all right and thank you
for continuing
to sponsor my show i want to thank
bluechu i want to thank stamps.com
and i want to thank the kings draftkings
for putting some money in your
[__] pocket this weekend
i love you guys sorry about this week
we'll be back monday morning
tip top magoo ready to light a homeless
[__] on fire
stay black be great
and that's it i love you [__]
so
you